gestes précis et concentration pour ces
élèves du lycée d'hôtellerie de
guyancourt qui tente de décrocher leur
place pour un concours international de
création de cocktails
un trophée qui s'adresse aussi bien aux
barmen professionnels qu'aux élèves
ils sont notamment jugés sur leur
technique on doit exécuter de telle ou
telle façon il faut bien au niveau du
shaker au niveau 2 de son matériel etc
il ya beaucoup de respect de règles à
suivre il faut suivre ces règles pour
que tout fonctionne correctement
autre critère pour s'imposer l'ogou le
cocktail doit obligatoirement contenir
un alcool le calvados thème également
imposé cette année les légumes
l'apparence la rom ou encore la
décoration sont scrutés à la loupe pour
moi celui ci manque d'équilibré ils ont
bien compris le thème de cette année qui
était le légume mai
celui ci
le légume prend bien trop le dessus par
rapport au calvados et l' équilibre
n'est pas au bout d'une heure et demie
le verdict tombe c'est mathilde et son
cocktail pink même à base de sirop de
vanille de jus de pommes de calvados et
de jus de betterave qui obtient le plus
de points en fait elle me faisait penser
une insight mais faisait quand quand
j'étais petit
inside justement il y avait de la pomme
et de la betterave et du cou
et puis la couleur est sympa donc je me
suis point que tel ça fouette bien fin
mars
l'étudiante défendra les couleurs de
guyancourt lors de la finale nationale à
caen